la paz vuelve al debate organizaciones
de Derechos Humanos Víctimas de la
guerra grupos opositores y ex
guerrilleros conmemoraron el 31
aniversario de la firma de los acuerdos
de paz que terminaron con la guerra
civil salvadoreña de los años 80 un
aniversario sin actos oficiales ya que
el gobierno de nayib bukele no reconoce
la fecha por diferencias políticas pues
ya tengo un insulto manifestar que los
acuerdos de paz fueron una farsa cuando
miles de personas murieron fallecieron y
existe impunidad en este país de muchos
casos que se dieron los manifestantes
rechazaron la intención de reelección
presidencial de bukele en 2024 y la
imposición de un régimen de excepción
que según cifras oficiales ha dejado más
de 60.000 detenciones criticadas por
organismos de Derechos Humanos
expresarme por las injusticias que se
están dando más que todo por la captura
de gente inocente Pues porque sin
antecedentes penales sin antecedentes
policiales no creemos en que justifican
estos
la fiscalía y el mismo gobierno de que
es procurar justicia Este no es un hecho
de procurar justicia Entonces nos
preguntamos Cuál es la verdadera
intención de estos hechos es claramente
un ataque y una venganza política contra
nuestros territorios organizados
los denominados acuerdos de paz de
Chapultepec en 1992 Fueron liderados por
Naciones Unidas y pusieron fin a uno de
los conflictos más sangrientos de
América Latina que dejó más de 75.000
muertos